we are the strong ones stronger together
this is a time for us
[Music]
welcome good evening and this year has
brought a lot of trials and tribulations
to families all over the country
and throughout those times of adversity
nevadans have shown that we
are stronger together thanks for joining
us i'm denise faldis and i'm brian
loftis tonight we'd like to take a
moment to highlight the times we've all
stepped up to help each other through
this difficult pandemic
at the height of covid19 one las vegas
nurse stepped in to help patients
in a city plagued by the disease we
start tonight with the story of teresa
hilton
she volunteered to travel to the bronx
to treat those infected in the icu for a
month
a news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke with her about her experience
treating patients
in one of the most infected areas in our
nation
i want it to help i want it to be there
to help people in order to be able to
you know give my skills from the icu
having just started in the telemedicine
department at southwest medical in las
vegas
teresa hilton berger responded to new
york governor cuomo's request for
medical help in their area
at the height of the kovit 19 pandemic i
put my name on the volunteer list about
going kind of giving my license
information
and literally i got a phone call a week
later
i got on the phone and i asked my boss
and i'm like dr
shay i'm like this they need help i was
like i feel like i need to go
and help with a green light from
southwest medical teresa traveled by
plane to the bronx new york
and volunteered her services with 1500
other nurses
you basically just got assigned a
hospital you
got put on a bus and told to show up and
then they would put you to work
theresa worked in the intensive care
unit at two locations
the governor's hospital and jacobi
hospital during her time there with the
virus being a new threat
she and her medical team did all they
could to comply
when they ran out of a piece of
equipment they used their own ingenuity
to fix it
and when ppe was scarce they adapted the
biggest takeaway for teresa was the
positivity among her colleagues
even in these trying times and getting
to see patients that she had treated at
the start
walk out of the hospital all of the
people that i got to walk out
and discharge or got to take down from
the icu
onto a step down floor
those were amazing moments madison
kimbrough 8 news now
teresa says because she's treated
patients in such a highly infected area
she now feels better equipped to educate
and communicate with her patients here
in las vegas
she says she's learning to give her
patients more reassurance and a better
assessment
of how to take care of themselves during
this time
well news of a successful coronavirus
vaccine is giving a huge boost to the
effort to stop the virus
pfizer's covid vaccine is on track to be
approved for use by the new year
and pfizer says early data shows its
experimental coronavirus vaccine
is more than 90 percent effective and it
will submit an emergency use
authorization with the fda once its
trial is completed
it has 50 million doses ready to go
about half
will go to americans dr anthony fauci
says
shots will likely be available for
people who want them by april
all the stars are starting to align very
very nicely
again you never want to get ahead of
yourself but this initial news from the
company
is extraordinarily encouraging the drug
company says it will be able to
manufacture at least
1.3 billion doses next year pfizer is
one of actually four vaccines in late
stage trials in our country
moderna is also reportedly expecting to
release some interim data very soon
well as we've seen far too often not
everyone survives covet there's an
emptiness in hundreds of thousands of
hearts that wasn't there before this
virus
but for families who've lost a loved one
the next steps take
strength and resilience and the examples
we've seen on display are pretty
awe-inspiring
here's the i-team's vanessa murphy
artur nazari's daughters are 10 8 and 5
years old
and it breaks my heart to see that
they're going to have to grow up without
a dad the 42 year old died in july
after contracting kovid 19. what would
you
think he would say is was his biggest
accomplishment oh absolutely his
daughters
without a doubt they were absolutely the
love of his life carissa hernandez says
she and artur's love started with a
friendship
and a passion for dance
[Applause]
from the first moment i ever laid eyes
on him i knew that he was going to be in
my life somehow or another
from dance partners to husband and wife
and this year
patient and caregiver after the parents
and their youngest contracted the
coronavirus
arter was then hospitalized whatever the
virus was doing within his own body
it was still somehow wreaking havoc in
his body carissa who's a nurse
says it was difficult to understand
because her husband was so healthy
still he contracted pneumonia and was
put on life support
since she and their girls couldn't visit
due to restrictions
she says hospital staff connected them
virtually on an
ipad for arter's final moments the
nurses were crying
the doctors were crying i could see that
this was
very personal to them you know as
painful as that was
i will be forever grateful that i was
able to fulfill the promise to my
husband that i would be there no matter
what to the end
and it's because of those nurses and
doctors that
they granted me that ability to fulfill
his
my promise to him months later she says
each daughter copes with the loss
in their own way the youngest not
grasping it yet
her understanding of this whole thing is
don't worry daddy will come back once
corona is over
and so i'm trying to explain to her that
unfortunately daddy's not coming back
even when corona is over
a lesson for three girls learned too
young
and a mother who's left to explain it
don't hesitate
to express how much you really love and
care for
your loved ones because the reality is
you never know vanessa murphy
8 news now other families have a much
different experience when their loved
ones recover from covet
not too long ago a ccsd principal was
one of those who recovered
following a really severe case lawrence
durasmo first spoke with eight news now
from his hospital bed in july
the 39 year old was uncertain at the
time if he would even survive
but he kept a positive attitude about
the situation despite the circumstances
and he did survive he credits the
steroids and antibiotics from doctors
along with all the community support for
helping him get better
and i really felt like it was just my
will and my determination and just
praying and just
just wanting to live and survive really
motivated me to
explore every option and just to try my
best to you know
get out of there after a seven week
recovery he returned to work at roger
bryant elementary school and helped his
school staff
prepare for the fall semester well there
are people hard at work trying to
prevent cobit altogether
and that includes people working on not
only a vaccine but also a cure
j.d miles introduces us to a 14 year old
texas girl
who won an award for her work on a
potential cobid cure
you only have to go to independence high
school in frisco
to find a student being called america's
top young scientist
it's exciting i'm still trying to
process everything a potential cure to
the influenza virus
meet anika shibrolu who at the ripe old
age of 14
recently won the 3m young scientist
challenge
and 25 thousand dollars it's for her
work on a cure for covet 19
or as she more accurately puts it and i
developed this
molecule which can bind to a certain
protein on the sars co2 virus and this
protein by binding to it
it'll stop the function of the protein
so i started with
over a database of over 698 million
compounds
anika was only in middle school when she
entered the contest months ago
and originally planned her project to
involve seasonal flu
she later changed it to covet 19 and
says she was driven
by the scope of the pandemic and the
people who were suffering
we just always have this constant fear
like who's going to get infected by the
coronavirus
anika describes herself as a typical
teenager who
not surprisingly plans to pursue a
career as a medical researcher
when she gets out of school my grandpa
when i was younger he used to always
push me towards science he was actually
a
chemistry professor and he used to
always tell me to learn the periodic
table of elements and
learn all these things about science and
over time i just grew to love it
right now she's balancing her search for
a coveted cure
in between classical indian dance
training and from these sketches
also practicing her skills as a very
good artist
i describe myself as a person who
aspires to be a lot of things that's
exciting to hear from this 14 year old
who's already accomplished so many
things
in frisco jd miles
and still ahead turning to the familiar
to help heal from coronavirus
we're going to meet one man who survived
and learn how his work is helping him
regain strength
while also making others in the valley
smile
and with thousands of people out of work
volunteers in our community stepping up
to keep families fed
coping after kovitt a las vegas artist
fought the virus and now his work is
helping him heal
the i-team's vanessa murphy shares neil
portnoy's story
we're at the world famous portnoy
gallery neil portnoy has called las
vegas home
for nearly five years it's the
entertainment capital of the world
and through his caricature art he's
become a verb
have you been portnoyed one of his
latest projects is yet to be unveiled
at allegiant stadium that's a legacy
that will be in that stadium
forever the 67 year old's legacy was on
his mind more than
ever in july during his battle with
kovid 19.
words from a health care worker stay
with him she said to me you literally
died twice his wife dorothy also
contracted the virus
a more mild case neal ended up in the
intensive care unit
people don't realize how bad it is it
gets mentally in your head
where you know you're not getting any
help you're not getting any better
it's scary it is really scary he credits
the drug rem deserver for
saving his life months later he's back
in his studio
all done for photos the better the
photograph
the better the final piece he's still
recovering after contracting pneumonia
followed by continued
treatment for blood clots he says he
previously had no
underlying health conditions he and
dorothy took precautions
and he isn't sure how they caught the
virus but he is grateful
has this changed your outlook on life
and
priorities absolutely you know i've got
a second chance
i'm going to do things that i wouldn't
have done before life is very short
it's very very scary and
you really need to not get upset over
things that
are really don't mean much you got to
get up every day
enjoy every day to its fullest because
we just don't know
vanessa murphy 8 news now
turning now to those who are always
there for those in need we're talking
about three square food bank
the purpose and the mission of three
square is to work with partners and
volunteers to lower the number of hungry
people in the valley
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
sits down with the ceo of three square
who says they found positivity in the
pandemic despite
tremendous need when the pandemic hit
three square chief operating officer
larry scott knew
they were soon going to have mouths to
feed but at the same time
volunteers dwindled and coveted
restrictions increase
it's been rough because we've had to
adjust
the way we do business we know that
serving the community
is best done with a personal touch
social distancing said
we still need food but but don't get
near us
that's not easy to accomplish good
morning fast forward eight months
volunteers are returning and helping
keep the flow of drive-through service
but these volunteers are different than
scott
has had in the past i was at the east
side cannery for our distribution here a
couple fridays
ago and had the opportunity to go
through the line and meet most of the
volunteers that were there
there were about 20 to 25 volunteers
most of them had lost their jobs better
for the next going please the volunteers
are furloughed or unemployed but they
were not staying home
i'm being sorrowful they were actually
out there helping and serving other
people
i watched one lady show up as
timid as the mouse and 30 minutes later
she was so joyful so excited to greet
all of the people that were driving
through the lines despite the pandemic
people are becoming resourceful and most
importantly
making a difference in their community
what's a beautiful thing though
is to see somebody who really doesn't
have much themselves
being willing to help a neighbor who
really has
almost nothing scott says three square
couldn't have continued their mission
without volunteers
those who made masks and others who
donated money
you are not alone in this we are
absolutely committed
to taking care of your food needs every
single day sally jaramillo
8 news now and scott would like to
remind the senior community that three
square has
the most robust senior hunger program in
the country
for instance they have a program that
they've contracted with lyft
where once a month they will bring a
senior to one of their pantries where
they can actually pick out the items
that they need
for more about that program you can go
to our website at 8newsnow.com
they do great work still ahead a new
team in a new town and they're making a
lot of people smile during the tough
times we'll take a look at how the las
vegas raiders are
helping out in the community
one of the bright spots in this pandemic
time is the las vegas raiders
the team is on the field in their new
stadium of course but the guys are also
very busy off the field
kevin martin joins us now to talk about
how the raiders have helped make times a
little easier for so many
in our community the raiders are
officially at the midway point of the
season
i think it goes without saying that so
far this has been one of the more
unconventional nfl seasons ever played
but the raiders have made the most of it
not just on the field
but also off of it making it a point to
still have a positive impact on the las
vegas community
here's a look back at the ways the
raiders were involved through the first
eight weeks of the season
tight end jason whitten took part in a
panel that discussed ways for the las
vegas community
to move forward united during the black
lives matter
protests everything that you would want
to be a part of
before i showed up if you said how would
you want it to go
not knowing what was going to happen i
would say exactly that i heard passion i
heard frustration i saw accountability
kicker daniel carlson and defensive back
lamarcus joyner spoke virtually to a
group of student athletes from liberty
high school
to be able to have our faith in our
voice and community
and giving back you know paying it
forward how it was given to us
i mean that's spiritual healing to me
and a group of raider alumni made a stop
at the metro police department k-9
division
to meet k-9 raider the newest addition
to the unit
who was purchased by the raiders and
several raiders including nelson aguiler
took part in a virtual escape room with
a special group of teens from the candle
lighters childhood cancer foundation and
the las vegas raiders are also
donating a five thousand dollars well
not donating they're giving a five
thousand dollar grant to the candlelight
program so thank you guys so much this
is just eight weeks into the inaugural
season and i think we all can agree
that we can't wait to see the silver and
black continue to have a positive impact
on our community
covering the raiders in las vegas i'm
kevin martin
and still ahead staying busy is a great
way to help bring normalcy to these
very unusual times we're going to
introduce you to a georgia woman taking
her skills to the outdoors
christmas
and a message from santa in finland on
what his hope for christmas celebrations
will be
well as we know once the pandemic hit
thousands of restaurants were just
forced to shut down
and if you're a food writer and there's
no food to write about well things can
look pretty bleak
unless you think off the menu here's
steve hartman
for atlanta-based food writer angela
hansberger
this pandemic has been hard to swallow
can't write about restaurants when
they're closed
i was facing a lot of anxiety i kind of
hit it
um gosh i'm crying
i was really sad for all the people in
the industry that i worked with
angela says she had to get her mind off
it tarragon
so using ingredients from her garden and
her encyclopedic knowledge of fine
dining
angela opened her own restaurant on her
front
porch where she now serves chipmunk
this chipmunk the little guy is at a
standing lunch reservation for months
now
whether it's veggie pizza and a side
salad or imitation
sushi with walnut wontons every day
angela goes to remarkable lengths for
her exclusive clientele
took a while to try and make little
tortillas
that i could fold to put the to put the
egg
i love the way that you're shaking well
i love how you're realizing how crazy it
sounds as you're saying it
today it's mini spaghetti with tiny date
meatballs
and a thimbleful of breadsticks the
chipmunk who she named
thelonious monk typically arrives within
seconds of serving
eats his fill and packs the rest to go
in his cheeky doggy bag
and the reviews have been good the
reviews have been great
one day he came up with this little tiny
bundle wadded up
leaves and put it on the table so i take
it to me and he brought
a tip still you get the sense that he
remains
skeptical like there's got to be a catch
angela's cat wishes there was
a catch but there will be none of that
because for angela this little bit of
silliness
has become her daily sustenance what has
it done for you
it's brought joy i have more videos of
this chipmunk than i have of my children
we all need to find a way to cope during
this pandemic
which is why i'm giving shay angela my
highest
rodent restaurant rating three stripes
steve hartman cbs news on the road
that is a world-class restaurant to that
chipmunk that is hilarious
finally tonight a very special message
from santa claus himself
the pandemic may change the way so many
celebrate the holidays but
we checked in with the big man and he
said there's no way the holidays are
cancelled
but we have to follow guidelines one of
the
most wonderful aspects of christmas
is spending time together that's true
certainly we have to follow and respect
all the public health recommendations
santa
what is your wish for this christmas
i hope we all stay safe
and i wish to see you soon be good
that's a message coming from finland's
arctic wonderland which usually attracts
many families each and every year but
santa's post office there receives
thousands of letters from kids across
the globe revealing
their wishes for christmas thank you so
much for watching our community pride
special stronger together
yeah we hope to serve as a reminder of
the resilience nevadans have thanks for
watching
you